today's episode is sponsored by blinka
Stu the app that lets you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blink it's totally
free and get 25% off a subscription when
you go to blink is comm slash David
Pakman I put the link right below this
video
welcome to the show it's a new week it's
a new day and it is not a new world in
terms of what's going on with
coronavirus it's much the same as what
was going on last week worse in some
places and yet Donald Trump had a rally
he did it
6,200 people showed up in Tulsa Oklahoma
not the sixty-two thousand that Donald
Trump predicted they didn't really have
1 million people trying to go as Donald
Trump's campaign manager claimed but we
will get to all of that and we're going
to spend some time today talking about
the different aspects of this rally
because there are so many stories and
types of stories and because they're so
emblematic of much of what is wrong with
the United States of America right now
so we're going to go through step by
step how Donald Trump's rally was
overhyped they claimed a million people
wanted to go
they got 6,200 it was irresponsible
Oklahoma is a coronavirus hotspot 6
Trump staffers sent in advance to set up
for the rally tested positive chock full
of ignorant people was the rally people
who vote and we're going to talk about
the issue of anti intellectualism in the
United States and the content of the
rally itself riddled with horrifying
admissions from Donald Trump each of
which would be a scandal in a normal
administration so I'm going to get to
crowd size in that part I'm going to get
to the public health component I'm going
to get to interviews with some of the
attendees we're going to get to all of
it but we have to start with what the
president said during the rally and what
Trump said during the rally was
illustrative of just how triggered
Donald Trump truly is because of the
things that people say on the internet
about him Donald Trump during this rally
spent more than 20 minutes just on his
water drinking and ramp walking
problems and Trump's actual speech also
shed light on the reality that Trump has
no real 2020 campaign message and this
is something I also am going to talk
about a little bit later things aren't
good
so Trump can't really campaign on things
being good unless he lies which he has
no problem doing and to some degree he
has been but the attacks on Biden are
mostly ad hominem so you've got no real
message attacks on your opponent are at
homonyms we have 20% real unemployment
and there is no actual case being made
for his reelection and that was very
much represented during this rally it
was one of the most jingoistic and
self-centered xenophobic ignorant horror
shows that I've seen in politics for a
long time and let's get into just a
couple of the specifics of what Donald
Trump said now this is this is a
borderline criminal admission that
Donald Trump made it's a murderous
admission Donald Trump admitted during
the rally that he asked for testing to
be reduced to be slowed down because he
knew if we tested more we would find
more cases this is borderline criminal
this leads to deaths it is murderous
take a look at what Donald Trump
admitted to test of what you do testing
to that extent you're gonna find more
people you're gonna find more cases so I
said to my people slow the testing down
please they test and they test we had
tests the people don't know what's going
on we got this we got another one over
here I really need people to understand
testing saves lives
this is tantamount to murdering people
deliberately it's not all we've been
struggling and we just haven't yet
gotten testing where we wanted this is
Trump saying the disaster of testing was
partially he was asking for testing to
be held back and the White House later
realizing the degree of insanity that
this is the White House later said it
was a joke there was no indication that
it was a joke this is not something to
even joke about obviously Andrea please
understand that testing finds more case
like in the short-term okay if we don't
do any tests today we don't find any
cases today but testing identifies
people who shouldn't be going out it
slows the spread and in the long run
more testing reduces cases the more
testing you do over the long run the
number of people who are testing
positive should decline and it is
murderuss to suggest do less testing now
Trump then again pulled out this
pejorative name for coronavirus kung flu
during the rally you could tell he was
sort of manic from the crowds energy
despite it being a far smaller crowd
than he was anticipating clearly still
hopped up from the crowd and throwing
kung flew out there it's a disease
without question has more names than any
disease in history I can name come flu I
can name 19 different versions of them
so the crowd cheering and in particular
you see one woman behind Trump who sort
of raised her fist and a sign of victory
I guess at Trump calling the virus come
flu certainly a Pyrrhic victory if
nothing else then Trump drank from a
glass of water and the crowd went wild
now that sounds weird it is weird think
about how low the bar is that Trump
drinking out of a glass of water with
one hand I guess to prove his critics
that he's able to do it he got a
standing ovation that is how low the
expectations are take a look Trump
drinking water throwing the glass aside
and the crowd goes absolutely wild and I
don't want to get water on the time and
I don't want to drink much so lift it up
the water I see we have a little glass
of water where the hell did this water
come from
where did it come from and I look down
on my tie cuz I've done it I've taken
water and it spills down and you type
doesn't look good for a long time and
frankly the tie is never the same so I
put it up to my lip at NSA because I
know what a sophisticated and they gave
me another disease they gave me another
disease
this is a very very sick guy
I said Trump doesn't have a 20/20
message maybe the messages I can drink
water with one hand and they think that
that that will be better than what Joe
Biden is offering maybe they're right
we'll know in four and a half months but
what a time to be alive
twenty minutes spent rambling about how
he can walk down a [ __ ] ramp and drink
water with with a single hand so it was
genuinely disgusting and also as I said
representative of so many of trumps
problems no message no vision a
disjointed speech in a red state that he
easily won and still unable to fill
barely a third of the 19,000 state seats
in the arena and we are supposed to
believe that there is any reasonable
case to re-elect this guy well that's
what I'm going to tackle next because
we're going to look at interviews with
Trump supporters at the rally and what
you will hopefully quickly realize is
that when these are your supporters
maybe you don't need the facts on your
side to justify reelection when these
are your supporters maybe it doesn't
matter that you have no case for your
own reelection let's talk about that
next so part two of our discussion of
the absolutely dystopian Trump rally in
Tulsa Oklahoma over the weekend is the
attendees yes there weren't that many of
them despite their predictions and we're
going to talk about that later on but
check out some of these interviews with
people who went there to support Donald
Trump now now I do feel the need to
issue a disclaimer here the goal here
isn't to make fun of people the goal is
to remind you some of these people vote
not all of them but some of these people
vote and when I explain week after week
after week why it's so important to get
out the vote in November this is going
to remind us of the importance because a
ton of these trumpets when you see them
talk you're going to realize that what
I've been saying is true they can't be
talked out of voting for Donald Trump
these are the people that we are talking
about
I say would it be easier to get five
leftist friends to vote people who are
not usually voters and just say hey it's
really important that you vote would
that be easier or would it be easier to
convince one of these people I'm about
to show you to vote and you will very
quickly see these are not people you can
talk sense into so the context here
remember is corona virus is spreading
wildly in Oklahoma and other red states
a huge part of the country doesn't seem
to believe it or believe that it's that
serious or believe that it warrants
social distancing and a lot of those
exact same people are the ones that
approve of the job that Donald Trump is
doing the ones saying I like what he's
doing I believe he's doing a good job so
let's start with Rosie Matlock check
this out she waited in line for four
days remember the stadium was two-thirds
empty why you would wait in line for
four days anyway is a question why you
would do it when the stadium is
two-thirds empty well she was
propagandized by Donald Trump about a
million requests for tickets and she was
interviewed by Andrew Kimmel this is
fascinating she's asked why have you
been sleeping in the chair for four days
waiting for Trump and she says well he
risked his whole life for us so I'm here
which almost suggests she's agreeing
that there's a risk to her life from
being at the rally right maybe I'm
missing the interpretation here but
let's take a look at it together from
and when when did you start waiting in
line Wednesday
so what brought you to come out on
Wednesday and are you sleeping out here
you've been sleeping in a chair that is
devotion and so you know what what is it
that makes you want to sleep on the
street sit in a chair for three nights
now so that's weird
and this next moment is just great this
is still Andrew Kimmel interviewing her
Rosie Matlock says what could get you to
not vote for Trump in other words is
there a hypothetical where if Trump did
X X would mean you don't vote for Trump
and she says well if he cheated on
Melania which of course Donald Trump did
and check out the direction this goes is
there anything that Trump can do that
would make you lose your support for him
she's amazing she is what every American
first lady should be well what about the
stormy Daniels thing because he was
married to her at that time
that was years ago before he ever became
president nobody is accountable for what
he done when he was a lot younger oh
okay
Trump was cheating on Melania but when
he was in his 60s now Trump is president
as a 70 plus year old man you can't hold
him accountable for that this is gold
because we often talk about asking
trumpets this question
what would make you not support Trump
she identifies something that would make
her not support Trump cheating on
Melania and Andrew Kimmel points out
well buddy did that and she says well
yeah but that was before he was
president of the United States if he
cheated on Melania now I wouldn't vote
for him you cannot convince them do not
even bother do not waste your time
please
let's continue here's at rumpus inside
the rally asked about virus concerns
says he's not worried because he can
always take hydroxychloroquine and take
a look I'm not concerned about the
spread I think in the general population
I'm seeing like a 0.4 0.2 percent
mortality rate even if you got it you're
not worried about no and even if I did
get sick from it I mean there's so many
positive studies with the hydrofluoric
Queen and zinc
the FDA got rid of they said you can't
prescribe it for them
no the FDA saying that it is able to be
prescribed they only shut it down for a
certain for a certain thing and actually
in Trump's roundtable the other day they
explained it very well so of course this
guy is wrong the emergency use
authorization was shut down patients on
hydroxychloroquine were not doing well
it's not working and what happened in
the roundtable is that Alexei czar
simply said it might work if taken
earlier we don't have any evidence of
that but that's what was set at the
round table so again important these
folks don't even comprehend what it is
that is said Alex a czar was lying when
he said this stuff in other words the
idea that they're optimistic about
giving it earlier there's no evidence of
that but it doesn't matter because
people like this voter will hear
whatever it is that they want to hear
here's another dude who has a friend who
died of coronavirus his friend's kid was
on a ventilator but here he is without a
mask around people without masks as
cases rage in Oklahoma his friend died
son on a ventilator almost died but we
don't know what the facts are well what
what are we talking about exactly I mean
is it a fact that your friend died is it
a fact that your friend's kid was on a
ventilator and then the motivated
reasoning is just fascinating listen I
know people who are concerned and
they're around groups of people without
wearing a mask so that must be evidence
that's okay that it's okay to do the
thing I want to do anyway but are we
talking about that being
at a rally of 6,200 people that seems a
little different and then here's the
cherry on top here's a guy who says that
Barack Obama assured in Marxism and says
how on earth did anyone vote for anyone
named Obama anyway oh and by the way
Obama also wasn't Obama's real name I
walked away from the Republicans back in
2006 once we gave him a trifecta from Oh
for 206 they spent like drunken sailors
and that became you know basically
Democrats so I walked away from him back
then you know then they you know half
the country's wealth was stolen in broad
daylight you know September of oh nine
nobody goes to jail except Bernie Madoff
and he was stealing from his own people
then of course they ushered in Obama to
normalize Marxism in the United States
of America he ended up for Hillary to do
us in you know I just you know you think
it'd be common sense you wouldn't vote
for a guy named Obama for President of
the United States particularly since
that wasn't even his real name but you
know Marxist Obama whose real name
wasn't Obama never should have been
elected on the basis of claiming to be
named Barack Obama it's interesting if
you're going to lie about your name
wouldn't you pick something that would
not be a turn-off to a large swath of
this country that is xenophobic and
racist and pick something other than
Barack Obama like as a fake name Barack
Obama seems like a horrible idea seems
Martin Smith might have been a smarter
fake name to take if that was the idea
so we can't convince them this is more
proof we've got to get out the vote
don't even waste energy just focus on
getting out the vote in the key
battleground in swing states we know
which ones they are
we know which states are likely to
determine who is the electoral college
Victor in November and that's where we
have to focus let me know what you think
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman remember that
we have a daily audio podcast which you
can get for free on any of your favorite
podcasting apps leave us a review if you
please on iTunes stitcher Spotify
you're poison all of them are available
we'll take a quick break more on the
rally attendance and Trump's rage at the
empty seats coming up after the break
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read ten books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinka Stan what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blankets to get
a sample first just think how much you
can enrich yourself by being able to
soak up an entire nonfiction book in
just 15 minutes I recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
Stephen Hawking this is a book that I
have been aware of for so long and other
things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
accom slash david pakman I've put the
link right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are robbing harley and i hope i do
this ok buchaiah to tech para UK to tech
para our today's new members of the day
also a big thanks to Josh auger Josh
auger has been a member for almost five
years and is today's longtime sustaining
member of the day grab a membership at
join pakman.com the number one way to
support this program okay let's now
discuss the crowd at Donald Trump's
rally Donald Trump's campaign was hugely
trolled on Saturday night and the the
story really bears telling because it is
so emblematic of how the Trump
administration and from campaign are
mismanaged
and also of how easily triggered and
thin-skinned Donald Trump and his
followers are so the venue were they
held the rally had a maximum capacity of
19,000 Donald Trump and his campaign
manager and a whole bunch of other
people were insisting we've had hundreds
of thousands of ticket requests we've
had a million tickets requested we are
not going to be able to fill the
requests there's too much demand so many
people want to go this will be a
historically huge rally and it couldn't
possibly have gone more embarrassingly
wrong in terms of attendance so first of
all the signs that things weren't going
so well were when they started putting
together this overflow stage which
Donald Trump believed that they would
need and the overflow stage was for all
the people who would show up and not be
able to get in in other words people in
excess of the 19,000 that could fit in
the stadium so they were going to do
sort of like a separate speech for the
overflow crowd maybe have Mike Pence
addressed them maybe have Trump talk to
them nobody was there they shut down the
entire overflow area while the rally was
still going on Secret Service clearing
the area and breaking down the American
flags and crowd control barriers just
not even necessary but here's the genius
part and we're still trying to figure
out the details on this there have been
a few different of ways this has been
presented it appears as though when this
event was announced and ticket requests
became available the form that you fill
out was was made
people not just from all over the
country but all over the world started
requesting a ton of tickets to make the
Trump campaign believe that there was
just overwhelming demand to go to this
Corona rally and watch Trump speak to a
huge crowd and this was the source of
Trump's campaign manager Brad Parr scale
claiming that a million people want to
go to this event but in the end the fire
department says 6,200 people went the
capacity was 19 thousand the entire
upper level was almost completely empty
much of the floor area was completely
empty and by the way imagine camping out
all week when in reality you could have
just walked up on the day of and gotten
right into this stupid rally now I do
want to be crystal clear because I don't
want people to think I just wanted I
don't want to send mixed signals is the
point I don't even think this rally
should have been held from the purp from
the perspective of coronavirus and we
should all be glad that 6,200 people
instead of 19,000 or 62,000 were there
that will save lives there will be
people who don't get the virus and some
who don't die because Donald Trump's
rally completely flopped versus if the
stadium had been full so I'm glad from a
public health standpoint that this
happened I'm glad from a political
standpoint as well but the degree of
embarrassment for the Trump campaign is
absolutely stunning stunning here is
Donald Trump saying we've never had an
empty seat and we're not going to have
one in Oklahoma this was just a few days
ago done a great job Oklahoma is at a
very low number they've done a really
fantastic work they have made new a
pretty new magnificent arena as you
probably have heard and we're getting
exact numbers out but we're either close
to or over 1 million people wanting to
go we have a 22 thousand seat arena but
I think we're going to also take the
convention hall next door and that's
going to hold 40,000 so of 22,000 plus
40,000 which would mean that would have
over 900,000 people that won't behave
to go but hopefully they'll be watching
but it's a it's an amazing nobody's ever
heard of numbers like this I think we're
going to have it we're gonna have a
great time we're going to talk about our
nation how funny is that Trump saying
between the arena and the overflow we're
going to have more than 60,000 people
they had 6200 here's a bunch of people
associated with Trump claiming that a
million people signed up for the rally
it's gonna be huge
the first person is governor's hit from
Oklahoma take a look and like you said I
don't know people caught that but over a
million people have requested tickets to
come to come to this advance look I
think your evidence though by seeing 1
million ticket requests for this rally
in Tulsa I think it's time they're so
excited about it that you have no idea
and we have had so many sign ups you
know there are lives of people now and
we won't be there for three days now
they have lines of people right now
trying to get into the arena I mean
they'll be there they'll be early how
many fill these finds us early front
rows how many people signed up do you
know over a million people requested
tickets well there's just a hunger for
the rallies though you have this massive
crowd you have nearly a million tickets
that are DeMaio are demanded out there
people pre filling out their
applications and why not to come in what
are you gonna do with all these people
that literally could be hundreds of
thousands of people trying to come and
you've only got 19 thousand seats
indoors what about all those other
people what are you gonna do with them
well there is an overflow crowd but it
really is a testament to people are
ready to move on and especially in
Oklahoma hearing the the word expecially
from a governor is always a little
jarring but the really jarring thing is
that they were expecting hundreds of
thousands of people to show up in
support of Donald Trump and 6200 showed
up a third of the arena's capacity and
that is good we should all be glad
because of how much better that is in
terms of coronavirus they sort of tried
to make it a little less embarrassing by
claiming 12,000 people were there but
again
the fire department is good at
estimating crowd size they said it was
6,200 people now there are rumors that
Donald Trump is furious with his
campaign manager Brad Parr scale we're
going to talk more about that later how
could Parr scale let Trump be this
embarrassed here is Trump when he landed
from the rally that night looking
extremely tired low-energy not happy and
I mean listen would you be happy if
after all this build up room for 62,000
including the overflow area a million
supposed ticket requests and you go and
there are 6,200 people and the entire
thing is mocked endlessly I'd also be
furious now one other thing some on the
right tried claiming that attendance was
lower than expected because of
anti-trump protesters okay the framing
was hundreds of thousands of people
60,000 people a million people did want
to go but because of these violent and
aggressive liberals that showed up and
intimidated trumpets Trump is stayed
away number one if you have a million
people that want to go and 6200 show up
you're saying that you know ninety-nine
point whatever percent of trumpets are
dissuaded from going to support their
Dear Leader
by some silly liberal snowflakes who
don't even carry guns showing up what
the rugged conservatives are going to
say sorry I'm not gonna go see our Lord
and Savior in person because of these
little liberals that showed up that's
actually the claim that you're making of
course it's complete and total BS and
what I'm going to show you next are some
clips of Trump campaign staff humiliated
when trying to explain away what
happened here so this video that I'm
going to show you is truly genuinely
delightful it is some old fashioned face
planting and it all happened on Fox News
you probably heard by now Donald Trump's
rally in Tulsa Oklahoma where he
expected 60,000 people for which they
believe they received a million ticket
requests they had 6,200 people show up
according to the fire department so
here's video of two different Trump
tools who went on Fox News who had no
way to explain
what happened other than to completely
collapse and it's just a pleasure to
watch this is total schadenfreude and I
completely admit it it is taking
pleasure in the failure of others but it
is pleasure for the greater good
if 19,000 people had shown up if 62,000
people had shown up it would have been a
disaster in terms of coronavirus spread
we should all be glad from a public
health perspective that only 6,200
people showed up so here's the first
video this is Mercedes slap a trump
campaign senior advisor watch and enjoy
campaign said that more than a million
people wanted tickets for this rally but
we all saw the pictures last night
the arena was no more than two-thirds
full and the outdoor rally that had been
planned for the overflow crowd was
canceled because there was no overflow
crowd question what happened well first
of all thank you for having me Chris and
happy Father's Day to you for let me
explain when it comes to understanding
how the rallies work it's a first-come
first-served basis basically what the 1
million RSVPs include it's an
opportunity for us to gather data to get
information and obviously so the key
here is that some that is important is
to understand then I had this with my
own personal family who lives not far
away from Tulsa that they were concerned
there were factors involved like they
were concerned about the protesters who
were coming in there were protesters who
blocked the mag's
and so we saw that have an impact in
terms of people coming to the rally but
what was amazing Chris was the fact that
over 5.3 million people watched it on
all of our digital media channels and so
the reach was far and wide and that
doesn't even include the TV numbers we
also did a pre rally show and that was a
over 2 million views so you know we're
living in a virtual time as well ladies
Mercedes a fake Mercedes if I can yes
the fact is the president talks about
the attendance at his events as we all
know it would he made a big issue of the
attendance at his inauguration he talks
about how he can fill an arena
and that Joe Biden can't he didn't fill
an arena last night and you know I'm so
far off let me if I may finish and you
guys were so far off that you had
planned an outdoor rally and there
wasn't an overflow crowd and I kept
watching the coverage and talking to
mark Meredith on the ground today
protestors did not stop people from
coming to that rally
the fact is absolutely they didn't tell
you there were people I'm telling you
there were people and families that
didn't want to couldn't bring their
children because of concerns of the
protesters oh it was first-come
first-served so then it wasn't a
completely embarrassing failure so you
know again with the protesters
silly liberal snowflakes apparently
scared off these rugged conservatives
from seeing their Lord and Savior in
person doesn't sound like the Alpha
behavior that they claim to exhibit does
it that that's your best argument so now
the issue isn't so much how many went
but she makes it about how many people
watched and of course a ton of people
were watching for the comedic and
dystopian elements there were a ton of
streams from the left ridiculing the
entire thing and again to believe that
if a million people wanted to go and
only 6200 showed up we're supposed to
believe that ninety nine point four
percent of the people that wanted to go
were scared off by liberals what a
pathetic argument to be making and then
you might have noticed that she went
into attacking Biden saying look Biden's
not bringing huge crowds Biden isn't
doing any big events Biden doesn't claim
that he's never had an empty seat at
every event that he does Biden is being
responsible in the context of the corona
spy or a corona virus pandemic because
some statistically people are going to
die because of that rally the rally was
held there will be some contagion that
happens that otherwise wouldn't and some
fraction of those people are going to
die fortunately it will be fewer than if
there had been 19,000 or 62,000 people
there just hilarious and then here's
another one named Jenna Ellis
she's a senior legal adviser to the
Trump 2020 cam
and she says thousands of people were
turned away which is sort of neither
here nor there but what I love in this
clip is she says look thousands of
people turned out four hours earlier
they were talking about a million ticket
requests and now she's bragging that
thousands showed up take a look not at
all this was a wonderful attendance and
we're so proud of all of the great
American patriots who showed up in
thousands to support the president in
his first rally in over three months and
listen the fact that there were so many
obstacles to overcome to even get into
the BOK Center there and still we had
over 6,000 people plus thousands more
outside that were turned away this was
an incredibly strong event and I think
it this is the most hilarious goal post
move that I've maybe ever seen a million
people supposedly requested tickets we
had thousands of people show up that's a
huge huge success what a victory you got
trolled including by what it seems were
just teenagers requesting tickets on the
Internet you would almost feel bad for
these people for looking so dumb on
national television and then you
remember they're choosing to show up and
be interviewed and defend this total
failure they're choosing to work with
the re-election campaign of Donald Trump
and this gets us back to an important
reminder rally crowds don't win
elections whether Trump had sixty two
hundred or six hundred and twenty or
sixty two thousand or six hundred and
twenty thousand people show up rally
crowds don't win elections if rally
crowds won elections Bernie Sanders
would currently be the Democratic
nominee there's one race that matters
and it's how many people vote in
November and you've got to do it figure
out what's going on with vote by mail
and absentee figure out which polling
places are being closed down we'll talk
about that in the context of Kentucky's
primary election tomorrow figure it all
out
because that's really the only thing
that matters make sure you're following
the david pakman show on instagram at
david pakman show we now have a video
that is going viral it's going altra
viral of me making a meal that I grew
from scratch in my backyard Oh
okay everything that I eat in this meal
it's this kind of a joke but you've got
to look at it for yourself I grew myself
in my backyard harvested prepared myself
okay that's david pakman show on
instagram don't miss it let me know what
you think the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world's famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show
alright so now we get to the end to the
sort of closing curtain of our
discussion of this absolutely pathetic
embarrassing ill-advised failed rally
that Donald Trump insisted on holding
and tool so Oklahoma Donald Trump was
completely furious outraged over the
large swathes of empty seats and he
flipped out on his own staff backstage
on Saturday he was completely triggered
and this might shock you
Trump blamed everybody but himself for
the failure so we already discussed what
Trump said at the rally including 20
minutes of material about walking down a
ramp and drinking water also admitted
that he tried to slow down coronavirus
testing we also saw interviews with
rally goers and the horrors that it
means about America we sought from
flunkeys fall apart when asked about the
lack of crowds on TV so now it's about
Trump and his reaction according to
people close to the White House Donald
Trump was furious behind the scenes
about the small rally crowd before the
rally even started six of Donald Trump's
ground team had already tested positive
for coronavirus that was the start of
Trump being furious Trump mad that it
got out that six of his staff got the
vibe
he wanted that information suppressed
then Trump had said he expected 22,000
people in the arena
40,000 more an overflow expecting more
than 60,000 people ended up with 6200
and Donald Trump became completely
unhinged and furious with his own
campaign manager Brad Parr scale
reportedly Trump's family including
Ivanka also furious with Brad Parr scale
one outside adviser said quote this was
a major failure they tried lying about
why the turnout was small offering up a
lot of protesters scared off rally goers
it was too hot the liberal media scared
people about coronavirus then they tried
lying about the crowd claiming it was
12,000 but the fire department says now
it was 6,200 people but the constant
thread throughout all of this is Trump
was losing his mind before and after the
rally there's a New York Times report
which explains that quote the president
who had been warned aboard Air Force One
that the crowds at the arena were
smaller than expected was stunned and he
yelled at aides backstage while looking
at endless rows of empty blue seats in
the upper bowl of the stadium according
to four people familiar with what took
place Brad parse scale the campaign
manager who had put the event together
was not present so the thinnest skinned
president that we've maybe ever had is
furious again and with everybody around
him but I don't want to miss this
opportunity to refresh what is maybe a
more important conversation whatever the
reason for the failed turnout a problem
they are up against is that they have no
coherent message for why Trump should be
reelected there are reports including
that there are growing concerns among
the Trump campaign officials that Trump
neither Trump nor his team have a
coherent message for why he should be
given a second term hijinks and
triggering aside the rally was notable
for the lack of actual campaign policy
message it was look at me I can drink
water coronavirus is overblown Joe Biden
is bad
20:16 was filled with promises he was
obviously not going to keep but at least
there were promises I'll build the wall
will repeal and replace Obamacare will
fix trade none of it happened and now
there's just nothing he can't really run
again on build the wall right I mean
that would just expose that he failed to
do it during his first term which is
what he had promised to do can he again
run on replacing Obamacare the plan he
proposed last time was terribly
unpopular and he's probably not going to
have the House of Representatives he may
not have the Senate remains to be seen
so what is the case for a second term
everything's terrible tomorrow on the
show we're going to talk about a new
poll where Americans are saying this is
the worst moment in American history
how do you justify your reelection Trump
being furious is of course about the
rally itself but there's a bigger
problem here which is what is the
argument to get yourself reelected if
you watch the rally
Eric Trump did a bit of a warm-up speech
which was insane and he brought up the
war on Christmas that is something Trump
talked about four years ago I guess we
supposedly won the war on Christmas
because Trump is president but is that
going to resonate with anybody when
we've got a hundred-year pandemic going
to be hopefully not but in the direction
of 200,000 deaths in the US by the time
of the election historically high
unemployment like is talking about the
war on Christmas going to work so we're
going to devote more time to this
tomorrow what is the case Trump is
making for his own reelection even aides
are worried that there is really no
coherent case being made more on that
tomorrow let's now take a little bit of
a look at what's going on with
coronavirus we've got four more days of
data the corona virus pandemic is kind
of settling now into trends that are
more about policy than early hotspots
and it is becoming very clear that it is
overwhelmingly red states where the case
growth is explosive now in the United
States in general red states have worse
education they have worse health care
they have lower incomes they have more
poverty
and these are trends that we've seen in
the United States for a long time now
early on in coronavirus there were many
right-wingers who were almost delighting
from seeing hot spots in large
democratic cities often within
democratic states we are now more than
three months in we're starting to see
corona virus spread correlate more with
policy than simply where did it go first
and with some small exceptions this is
increasingly a red state problem take a
look at this map where you will see a
county-by-county growth level where
either the trends are going in the right
direction or in the wrong direction and
this is a much more precise way than
simply looking at states or the country
if your while described to you what
we're looking at but if you're watching
you will notice there are green and
yellow colored counties those are doing
well that means they are either fully or
almost under control with coronavirus
you then have orange and red counties
which are not good okay and as you can
see huge swaths of the country including
the Northeast most of the West Coast
other than California which continues to
be a problem much of the bluer states in
between are going in the right direction
and yet at a country level we have crazy
numbers of new coronavirus cases how can
this be well it's because of the really
disastrous red state counties almost all
of Arizona's going the wrong way large
parts of Texas Louisiana Alabama
Arkansas Oklahoma Georgia both Carolinas
Florida and if you look at day to day
case numbers the places that are now
regularly having the new single day case
records are still California we've
talked about California but then it's
places like Florida Texas Arizona again
the Carolinas Georgia a couple of the
early hot spots New York and Illinois
but then Tennessee Virginia Ohio so do
we have a unifying theory about what is
going on here we we actually do and I'm
going to tell you what it is so that
when these right-wingers trot out the
bogus talking points you don't fall from
them if all for them some of the talking
points we're hearing from the right are
things like this
is a Democratic City problem which
spread no thanks to them into red states
it's the fault of the Democrats we've
heard red states have more cases because
they have more testing we've heard this
was allowed in from China because of
stupid liberal blue state governors and
now we all have a problem thanks to them
we've heard the numbers are simply fake
we've heard southern states are a
problem because Mexicans are bringing
the virus across the border all of this
is wrong all of this is wrong Trump
brags that now no one is coming over the
us-mexico border Trump has said the
border is stronger than ever
other than States lying about how low
they claim cases to be the huge case
numbers are not because there is more
testing going on there really are more
cases this is all not true and here's
the unifying theory to understand early
on late 2019 early 2020 before we knew
what was going on before we understood
the disease and how its spread the
disease was seeded planted in urban
areas with high direct traffic to the
early hot spots so here in Boston we
have tons of flights to Europe and to
China and other parts of Asia non-stop
flights here to Shanghai Hong Kong Japan
multiple city you know Beijing etc so it
was seeded here in Boston New York has
two major airports that connect directly
to China in Europe JFK and Newark
Pennsylvania was an early hotspot
American Airlines has a huge hub in
Philadelphia huge flight hub back and
forth to Europe and even some flights to
Asia Chicago is a big hub for American
Airlines and United many international
airlines also have nonstops to Chicago
you've got Los Angeles and San Francisco
airports so for two to three months
coronavirus was being seeded before we
knew what was going on and that's why
those were the early hotspots when we
learned about what was going on and
started stay at home orders those places
already had a huge amount of disease
before we even had testing capacity it
was spreading for weeks and you had a
large base population
which contributed to huge spread in
these places we had it here in Boston
New York Chicago etc so early the spread
was heavily related to where are people
flying in and out of and giving it to
other people now over time some states
adopted serious policies for mitigation
and some states did not and over time
the numbers became less about flights
and air travel which have all but
stopped but more about policy and once
you let the policy differences play out
for a few months
you see these dramatic reductions in
places that were early hotspots
Massachusetts New York Illinois
Pennsylvania which are crushing the
disease right now fortunately I'm really
thrilled by the way about what's going
on here in Massachusetts things slowly
reopening safely reopening which is good
to see and you see the explosion in the
places that didn't have strict
guidelines or they were simply ignored
that's what's going on in California by
the way California has strict guidelines
but from all of the people I know living
there a lot of people are just ignoring
them
that explains California it also
explains Arizona Florida Carolinas
Georgia Oklahoma Arkansas Alabama
Louisiana as the new growing hot spots
so policy clearly does matter and at the
rate things are going
if you don't reverse what's going on
right now in 15 days you are going to
have a large portion of the us-south
that is going to be the world hotspot
the there are states already Arizona's
growth rate for cases exceeds some of
the worst countries right now Arizona on
its own and meanwhile Donald Trump held
a rally in such a hot spot Oklahoma
whose case rate is going up dramatically
so that is the lay of the land
right now we'll have some more detail
about this tomorrow I am now on cameo
you can book me to troll your friends I
got booked for a bunch of Father's Day
messages this week
Kamio dot-com slash David Pakman or just
search my name on the cameo app tomorrow
I'm gonna have a really 20 video I
for somebody on cameo but we'll take a
quick break and be back after this the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
one of the preferred and primary
strategies for Republicans to win
elections for a long time has been
suppress the vote make it more difficult
for people especially people who are
less likely to vote for Republicans to
vote and this has been done a whole
bunch of different ways reducing the
number of polling places reducing early
voting up urging people from voter rolls
there's a very long list of tactics
we've talked about over the years and
the 2020 strategy is going to be really
suppress the vote even more than usual
we've already started to see it in some
primaries around the country in local
elections and Kentucky is scheduled to
have a primary tomorrow and we may well
be seeing the exact same thing now
normally there are 3700 polling places
in Kentucky tomorrow there will be 200
you didn't hear that wrong 3700 there
will be 200 that's a 95% reduction in
polling places now there's a
double-edged sword here and the
right-wingers are trying to play both
sides of the coin so to speak and the
reason that's being given for this
reduction in polling places is because
of the corona virus pandemic a lot of
poll workers don't want to work if you
can't staff polling places you have to
close them now that is certainly
plausible the problem is that in that
case you have to ensure that people can
vote by mail you have to increase
capacity dramatically at the polling
places that will be open and there are
widespread reports that people who
requested absentee ballots haven't
received them and it's the day before
they have to be mailed out they'd have
to be postmarked by tomorrow Election
Day so understand that on one hand they
are pretending to respect the virus you
can't put people in harm's way and great
I mean I'm totally with you as far as
that goes
but they're not doing what needs to be
done to make sure people can vote by
mail or vote early
which is exactly what Republicans
including Kentucky Republican senator
Mitch McConnell who's up for re-election
by the way in November and his
challenger is going to be determined in
this primary tomorrow that's what
McConnell wants that's what Donald Trump
wants as well now some early voting has
been enabled they at least claim that
they're trying to keep up
requests for absentee ballots but it's
just not working and this is it's sort
of a hanlin's raiser situation never
attribute to malice that which is
adequately explained by stupidity or I
might say incompetence they claim that
they did everything right
not enough poll worker so they said hey
vote by mail request absentee ballots
there's gonna be some early voting etc a
residents were sent postcards explaining
how mail-in voting will work early
voting has been available in some places
since June 8th and the media and the
governor they've all been telling
everybody that this is this is going on
so there are people saying we did
everything we could we really did given
the circumstances but at the same time
you know when you read that half of
Kentucky's black voters live in one
County and that County will have one
polling place that's rarely a
coincidence when we see that type of
thing around the country so while I
don't want to attribute to malice that
which can be adequately explained by
incompetence or stupidity or ignorant
when you read that half of the black
population is in one County which will
have one polling place it doesn't sound
good it doesn't sound good and certainly
to some degree they were unprepared I'm
reading that instead of the normal three
to five days that it takes to receive an
absentee ballot application some are
taking upwards of twenty days I've
gotten emails from people in Kentucky
under that situation so what will happen
tomorrow well we know what's going to
happen whether it's malice or
incompetence tomorrow you are going to
have overcrowding polling places that
are open the ones that are open are
gonna be absolutely busting at the seams
people will not have received their
absentee ballots in many cases and they
will have to decide do I go out and risk
catching the virus and maybe waiting
hours and hours at a completely
overloaded polling place or do I just
not vote because I didn't receive an
absentee ballot in the mail and then you
will have a situation that will be
similar to or even worse than the one we
saw in Georgia just a few weeks ago so
there
some important decisions to be made
tomorrow in Kentucky there is again a
Democratic primary race to decide who
will be facing off against Mitch
McConnell in November there is Amy
McGrath Charles Booker and some other
candidates that's a big decision there
are some interesting House primaries as
well for the eventual November House of
Representatives elections happening in
Kentucky so this isn't nothing and again
it's all a preview of what's going to
happen in November the turnout tomorrow
is not going to be as big as the number
of people that will vote in November
because you will have everybody coming
out to vote for either Joe Biden or or
Donald Trump if you see chaos tomorrow x
52 imagine what it is that's going to be
happening in November again is it by
design is it incompetence is it
stupidity I don't know for sure it's
often a combat combination of all of the
above let me know what you think we have
a voicemail number which is two one nine
two David P I love this voicemail this
is a delightful caller who thinks Trump
may have lied about how great he is for
black Americans take a listen to this
one of my new favorite callers well I am
definitely going to vote for vice
president body with all Americans need
to go out there and vote for November
the 3rd yes we need to get that
dangerous person out of the White House
he's very dangerous and he is the
laziest president if we la he said he's
done more for black people than any
president he told a lie that's right
which we all know how lies we do and of
course always welcomed the David Pakman
show playing in the background while the
caller leaves a voicemail yes you are
completely right Donald Trump's claims
about how great he's been for black
America is that their claims that that
are a joke we've debunked them
individually we've got to get them out
it is more the last 48 hours and what
happened at the rally have renewed the
urgency of removing this guy on the
bonus show today by the way another
reason to get him out Donald Trump has a
new plan
for ending dacha last week the Supreme
Court rejected Trump's argument for why
Dhaka should be cancelled and we said
he's going to try it again and he may
win if he tries it again there is a plan
that could take six months to complete
Trump will still be in office in six
months but oh wait no no yes marcha did
December yeah he will still be in office
in six months but he will be close to
out if if if if we replace him in
November by voting for Joe Biden and no
surprise that there is a new plan we'll
tell you what it is to get rid of daca
on the bonus show we will also talk
about the project to map the ocean floor
very interesting science project and and
I'll tell you why it matters and we will
also tell you the latest coronavirus
shortage we had toilet paper we then had
bicycles
it is now coins coins and I will explain
why become a member and get instant
access at join pakman.com
thanks so much for watching today's a
full episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinka the app that
lets you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try bling kissed for free and save
25% off of a subscription when you go to
blink is comm slash david pakman i've
also included the link right underneath
this video